well the war in ukraine has forced
nearby turkey to play a delicate
balancing act that means supporting kiev
with drones but at the same time
refraining from sanctions against russia
the conflict has also raised tensions in
istanbul a welcoming oasis for both
ukrainian refugees and russian tourists
dw correspondent yulia han has more
four years old
[Music]
ukrainian children
killed in the war
does not want them to be forgotten
the 49 year old has been living in
turkey for many years but her son and
grandchildren remain in ukraine
for months she and a group of others
have been protesting here in istanbul
city center
every single day
since russia's invasion of ukraine began
in late february
what has this baby done
what do all the other ukrainian children
have to do with this war
at least 360 have been killed so far and
we don't know how many are still buried
under the rubble
we are here for the sake of these
children we want them to live
i want my grandchildren to live
tens of thousands of ukrainians have
come to turkey since the war started
but also many russians
every day planes from moscow land in
istanbul
turkey is courting russian tourists
and president recep tayyip erdogan is
performing a delicate balancing act
supporting kiev
while trying not to jeopardize his
relations with the kremlin
turkey is one of the few countries in
the region that hasn't imposed sanctions
on moscow that is why many russians
still come here and encounter ukrainians
and that as you can imagine also leads
to conflicts
recently experienced this herself
she shows me video footage of passersby
russians as she says who clearly show
their disgust for the demonstrators
not an isolated incident
i find that deeply offensive we are not
here for fun or protesting for some
trivial reason
we're here because we want the whole
world to know what's happening in our
country
that people are being killed every day
including children
then people like that come along and
make fun of us and insult us
but olina and her fellow protesters
don't want to be intimidated
they want the killing in ukraine to
finally end
and until then they say
they will keep on demonstrating here in
istanbul
every single day